[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم قال حلف النيتو ان
الموقف الروسي من الازمه في اوكرانيا يهدد
الامن والسلم في اوروبا ياتي ذلك بالتزامن
مع نبره تصاعديه في العواصم الغربيه تجاه
تلويح موسكو باستخدام الحل العسكري في شبه
جزيره القرم نتوقف اذا مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في محورين اولا ما دلاله دخول حلف
الناتو على خط الازمه الاوكرانيه المحتدم
بين الغرب
وروسيا ثم هل تبدو في الافق بوادر لحل
سياسي يمكنه كبح جماح لغه التصعيد
العسكري
تتسارع اذا الاحداث في اوكرانيا بعد دخول
قوات روسيه الى شبه جزيره القرم تتراوح
ردود الفعل الغربيه ما بين تصعيد دبلوماسي
اوروبي لا يصل الى درجه القطيعه وتهديد
امريكي باتخاذ اجراءات تظل اقل من الخيار
العسكري النيتو من جهتها اعتبر روسيا خطرا
على السلم والامن في اوروبا وما بين
التهديد والتحذير لم يفقد الغرب
والاوكرانيين رهانهم على الخيار السياسي
للخروج من
الازمه النيتو على خط الازمه يجتمع على
عجل للبحث في التداعيات المتسارعه للازمه
في اوكرانيا يستبق الامين العام للحلف
الاجتماع باتهام روسيا بتهديد السلم
والامن في اوروبا يطالبها بوقف انشطتها
العسكريه في جوارها
الاوكراني الوضع بالغ الخ
يقول راسموسن ما يوجب تفعيل البند الرابع
من ميثاق النيتو وذلك ينص على ضروره ان
تتشاور دول الاعضاء اذا شعرت اي دوله عضو
بان استقلالها السياسي او امنها وامن
وسلام المنطقه في خطر هذا ما طالبت به
بولندا ولاتفيا التتان دعت للاجتماع
وكلتاهما على خلاف اوكرانيا عضو في النيتو
الازمه اذا هي الاسوا براي محللين منذ
الغز السوفيتي لتشيكوسلوفاكيا عام 68 من
القرن المنصرم وتمثل واحدا من التحديات
الامنيه المتلاحقه والجديده على الحلف في
حقبه ما بعد الحرب البارده فبعد تدخله في
البوسنه سادت قناعه لدى كثيرين بان تلك هي
اخر الحروب في اوروبا وان نطاق تدخل الحلف
سيكون خارج مناطقه التاريخيه ليعيده
التدخل العسكري الروسي في شبه جزيره القرم
الى معادلات الحرب البارده
نفسها السبب كما يقول الغرب هو روسيا التي
تتصرف باسلوب القرن التاسع عشر على حد وصف
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لقد غزت بلدا اخر
وعليها ان تقلب خياراتها لنزع فتيل الازمه
والا واجهت اقصى مدى من العزله كما قال
كيري وهدد ويشمل ذلك خساره عضويتها في
مجموعه الثمان واحتمال تجميد ارصده
الشركات الروسيه وسوى ذلك من تبعات قال
كيري انها خطيره جدا ذلك يكشف رهانا غربيا
على الضغط الدبلوماسي والتهديد الاقتصادي
ويستبعد الخيار العسكري لكن توسيع نطاق
التدخل الروسي في اوكرانيا خارج منطقه
القرم في حال حدوثه من دون رد قد يكون
اختبارا عسيرا للغرب وتحديدا الولايات
المتحده كدوله كبرى يتراجع نفوذها في
العالم من ازمه الى اخرى
وموضوع حلقتنا هذا اذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا
من موسكو الينا سوبونينا مديره قسم الشؤون
الدوليه في في جريده ريما الروسيه ومن
لندن سينضم الينا اندي هندر مدير المعهد
البريطاني لابحاث الشؤون الاوكرانيه ومن
كيف ينضم الينا صلاح زقوت مدير جمعيه
البيت العربي في اوكرانيا اذا نرحب
بضيوفنا جميعا ابدا من موسكو ابدا معك
الينا سوبونينا كيف قرات موسكو برايك
تصريحات الامين العام لحلف النيتو راسموسن
التي قال فيها ان روسيا تشكل عامل تهديد
للامن والسلم في
اوروبا رد الفعل الغربي وحاد جدا
والوضع في بالغ الخطوره امس كانت تصريحات
مستشار الرئيس الاعلامي السيد بسكوف وهذه
التصريحات تفتح ابواب
لايجاد نقاط التفاهم ما بين روسيا والغرب
لانه كما قال السيد بسكوف اجراءات متخذه
ليس بالضروري ممكن ان تؤدي الى تدخل عسكري
وهذا يعني بانه روسيا مستعده ان تتفاوض
ولكن هناك عده امور ممكن ان تغير بسرعه
هائله هذا الموقف وهذه الامور تتعلق قبل
كل شيء بالوضع في داخل شبه جزيره قرم
وهناك كثير اذا كانت روسيا مستعده للتفاوض
لماذا لم تبدا بالتفاوض بدل التهديد
بالتدخل
العسكري انا قلت ان روسيا مستع عدي
للتفاوض ولكن ايضا اضفت بانه الاوضاع على
الميدان ممكن ان تغلق هذا الباب لانه اذا
طلبت شبه جزيره قرم
باستقلاليتها عن باقي اجزاء اوكرانيا فلا
بد من روسيا ان
تحمي المدنيين في القرم بالاضافه الى ردود
الفعل الغربيه لحتى الان ه هذه الردود هي
حاده جدا
وهي لا تقول بان الغرب مستعيدا ليتفاوض مع
روسيا ومستعدا ياخذ بعين الاعتبار مصالح
روسيا فهذا الشيء ما ت ا تعتبرين ان ردود
الفعل الغربيه هي ردود فعل حاد كما ذكرتي
الان اندي هندر في لندن يعني ردود
الفعل اقوى ربما رد فعل هو رد فعل الناتو
راسموسن قال اليوم ان النيتو يعتبر ان
التدخل الروسي الموقف الروسي فيه تهديد
للامن والسلم في اوروبا كيف سيتصرف النيتو
برايك اذا هذا الخطر
اذا
اعتقد ان الوضع خطير للغايه وعلينا ان
نفهم تدخل الولايات المتحده والملكه
المتحده وان سبب ذلك هو انه عندما استقلت
اوكرانيا في عام
فكانت تتمتع بثالث اكبر قرسان نوويه في
العالم وهذا يعطيكم فكره عن مد بالقول
بانها اكثر من فرنسا والصين سويه
وبالتالي تخلت عن قوتها النوويه طوعيا مع
تطمينات الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده وروسيا بان لو اي من سياده
الاقليميه لبلدهم تعرض للخطر وسياده البلد
تعرضت للخطر فان هذا هذه الدول ستقدم
ضمانات للسلامه
الاقليميه في مستقبل البلاد لهذا نشد ان
نشهد ان الغرب يتدخل او يشارك لانه كان
قدم مثل هذه التطمينات الى اوكرانيا لقاء
تخليه عن ترسانته النوويه طيب سيد صلاح
زقوت يعني نريد وانت في كيف ان يعني
تحدثنا قليلا عن الجو العام اذاء هذا
التطور رد الفعل على مستوى الراي العام
على المستوى
الحكومي في اوكرانيا وتحديدا في كيف وعلى
من يعولون في اوكرانيا اذاء هذه
الاخطار على المستوى اولا مساء الخير لك
ولكل ضيوفك الكرام على المستوى الشعبي
هناك حاله من القلق
والترقب رغم ان الشعب الاوكراني هو شعب
مسالم ولا يرى في اللجوء الى الخيارات
العسكريه حلا للمشكله وهم يعتبرون ان ان
الروس هم اخوه لهم وهم شركاء لهم بالتالي
هم يطمحون ان تسود الحكمه والعقل من اجل
حل كافه المشاكل العالقه بين اوكرانيا وما
بين روسيا على المستوى الرسمي هناك حاله
من الاستعداد الكامل واليوم تم دعوه
الاحتياط وتم صرف الموازنات
للقوات المسلحه لمواجهه اي تهديدات
بالتدخل العسكري لان من واجب الجيش
والحكومه الاوكرانيه ان تدافع عن وحده
وسلامه الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا هو الجو
العام وكما تسمعون انا خلفي الميدان هناك
جماهير محتش وهناك خطابات تؤكد على وحده
اوكرانيا ورفضها لاي تدخلات
خارجيه طيب السيده الينا سوبونينا يعني
تابعتي بلا شك ردود الفعل الغربيه
والامريكيه جون كيري
يعني انتقد كثيرا الموقف الروسي وذهب الى
حد تهديد روسيا
بالعزله بعقوبات وقال انها ستدفع الثمن
غاليا هل برايك تسرعت روسيا في اتخاذ قرار
ب قرار المجلس الفيدرالي بمنح بوتين
صلاحيه التدخل عسكريا في
اوكرانيا روسيا لم تتسرع وروسيا كانت تقرا
بدقه ما يحدث في شبه جزيره قرم الاحداث
نفسها هي دفعت روسيا لاتخاذ اجراءات
مطلوبه وموسكو لحتى الان اتخذت اجراءات
قان قانونيه وهناك تعبئه عسكريه على
الحدود نعم هناك قوات خاصه موجوده الان في
شبه جزيره القرم ولكن ليس لحتى الان هناك
تدخل عسكري بمفهوم حقيقي لهذه الكلمه
فبالفعل
القرار الحاسم لحتى الان لم
يتخذ وهو السيد بوتين الذي
سيتخذ هذا القرار وبدات الايام القادمه
ستكون حاسمه جدا وايضا الاستفتاء في شبه
جزيره القرم في نهايه مارس سيكون له دور
مهم للغايه ف نعم نحن نحن اخوه مع
اوكرانيين ولكن في نفس الوقت سياح روس
تعرضوا
لهجومات في الاوكرانيه في اشهر الاخيره
مواطني روسيا يتعرضون للاهانات في غرب
اوكرانيا كل ه هذه
احداث اثرت على موقف موسكو في الايام
الاخيره هل تبدو هذه التبريرات مقنعه
استاذ اندي
هندر
انانيا تعيش كدوله مستقله منذ 32 عاما وهي
دوله مسالمه للغايه ولم نشهد اي قضايا
تتعلق بالعنف خلال السنوات الماضيه فيها
واعتقد ان ما شاهدناه وخاصه في منطقه
القرم هي مجتمع متعدد العرقيات فهناك
الروس وهناك الاوكرانيين وايضا وهناك تتار
وهؤلاء مسلمون وكان كان قد رحلوا ايام
ستالين في
الاربعينيات من القرن الى اسيا الوسطى
وبعد استقلال اوكرانيا عادوا الى
اوكرانيا وبالتالي هؤلاء اختاروا مستقبلهم
ان يكون مع اوكرانيا وعاشوا في القرم ولا
يردون يعيش تحت حكم موسكو وبالتالي
الموضوع الكبير حاليا هو بالنسبه هؤلاء
300 الف متري في منطقه
القرم الذين لن يقبلوا اطلاقا تحت اي ظرف
ان يكونوا تحت حكم كان في السابق قد
اضطهده ورحلهم وبالتالي اعتقد ان الغرب
هذا هو ما سيركز عليه الغرب وخاصه في بم
القرم وحول مستقبل هؤلاء 300 ال
تتري في القرم وهم مسلمون ويعيشون في
اوكرانيا طيب استاذ صلاح زقوت يعني الى اي
مدى تعول
فعلا كيف الان على النيتو وهذا الموقف
الجديد من النيتو وعلى الغرب للتصدي لاي
عمل عسكري روسي
محتمل القياده الاوكرانيه
طلبت رسميا من الولايات المتحده ومن
بريطانيا ان تحافظ على وحده وسلامه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفق اتفاقيه تسليم
الاسلحه النوويه بالتالي انا لا اعتقد
والقياده الاوكرانيه تدرك جيدا انه ان
الولايات المتحده او الناتو لن يقدموا
مساعدات او يدخلوا في حرب مع
روسيا الاتحاديه بالعكس القياده
الاوكرانيه الان تلتزم اقصى درجه من ضبط
النفس وقالت انها لن تنجر للاستفزازات انا
اكنها في نف الوقت قلقه
جداص تبدو قلقه جدا يعني اعلنت اعلنت
اليوم انها على شفير كيا انها على شفير
كارثه بعد اعلان الحرب عليها من جانب
روسيا وانها بدات تفقد السيطره سريعا على
شبه جزيره
القرم حقيقه الوضع بالتاكيد
يعني خطير جدا والقياده تدرك ذلك انا
اعتقد ان المساله الاساسيه هي يجب خلق
تطمينات
لروسيا الاتحاديه ان اوكرانيا لن تكون في
اي حلف من الاحلاف بما يهدد مصالح روسيا
الاتحاديه روسيا تخشى ان تنتقل اوكرانيا
الى حلف الناتو وهذا وا اوكرانيا هي خاصره
روسيا وهذا يشكل خطر على المصالح الروسيه
اعتقد اذا وجدت تطمينات من قبل القياده
الحاليه ومن الولايات المتحده ومن الغرب
ان اوكرانيا لن تدخل في اي احلاف اعتقد ان
المساله جزء كبير من المساله سينتهي بعد
ذلك هناك قضايا من الممكن التفاوض عليها
نعم اذا سناخذ الان فاصلا قصيرا بعد هذا
الفاصل سنعود لنقاش هذا سنسال هل من حل
سياسي يمكنه كبح جماح لغه التصعيد العسكري
مشاهدينا لا تذهبوا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
عائدون مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد
الى هذه الحلقه التي تناقش تطورات الازمه
في اوكرانيا في ضوء اتهام النيتو لروس
بتهديد السلم والامن في اوروبا في بدايه
هذا الجزء الثاني يعني استاذن من الينا
سوبونينا واندي هندر بالعوده مره اخرى الى
صلاح زقوط لانه سيغادر مباشره بعد الاجابه
على هذا السؤال لاسباب تقنيه اذا كنت قبل
قليل استاذ صلاح زقوت تقول ان كيف عليها
ان تقدم تطمينات لروسيا بانها لن تدخل في
اي حلف من الاحلاف وهو هذا ال هاجس بالفعل
الذي يقلق روسيا الى اي مدى برايك كياف
لديها هذا الاستعداد انها لن تنضم الى
النيتو لن تنضم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
اي من الاحلاف التي تقلق روسيا باختصار لو
سمحت اعتقد ان النخبه السياسيه في كيف
الان تدرك اهميه هذا الموضوع واعتقد ان
الشارع الاوكراني بمختلف اتجاهاته مع هذا
التوجه لان
اذا ارادت ان تحافظ على وحدتها واستقلالها
وسلامه اراضيها يجب ان تاخذ لان روسيا
لديها اوراق قوه كثيره تستطيع ان تلعب بها
غير الجانب العسكري هناك الجانب الاقتصادي
هناك الجاليات الروسيه هناك العلاقات
التاريخيه والثقافيه مع شرق
ومع ومع جنوب اوكرانيا بالتالي هناك ادراك
وانا اعتقد ان ان البرلمان اعد شروع قرار
لاعاده اللغه الروسيه كلغه محليه في
المقاطعات بالتاكيد الحكومه الجديده حقيقه
تسرعت في بعض القرارات
التي اخذتها كذلك موسكو تشعر انها الروسيه
الكره و نعم شكرا جزيلا لك صلاح زطوط مدير
جمعيه البيت العربي في اوكرانيا كنت معنا
من كيف شكرا جزيلا لك نواصل النقاش مع
ضيفنا الينا سبون
اندي هندر الينا سوبونينا يعني هو بالفعل
يعني لو تت يعني لو تقدم كيف تطمينات
لروسيا بانها لن تنضم الى اي من الاحلاف
الموجوده وعلى راسها حلف طبعا النيتو هذا
هو الحلف الاكثر يعني المصدر الاكثر قلقا
بالنسبه لروسيا هل تحل المشكله برايك
برايك لو تقدم هذه الحكومه شيئا ما ملموس
ل تهدئه الامور
فنعم حل الحل السياسي هو ممكن رغم انه
التصعيد هو مستمر والوضع خطير جدا الحكومه
الانتقاليه في اوكرانيا ارتكبت باخطاء
كثيره واستفزت موسكو بكثير من قراراتها
الاخيره واصلا المشكله ايضا انه هذه
الحكومه لا تسيطر على الاوضاع في اوكرانيا
هناك مناطق عده في هذه البلاد لا تخضع
للحكومه المركزيه في مدينه كيف هناك مناطق
فيها فوضه كامله هناك مناطق تريد ان تدرس
موضوع تقرير مصيرها مثل قرم وليس فقط قرم
هناك مدن مثل خاركوف ودونباس ودونيتسك
كلها تقع في شرق اوكرانيا وهي لا تحترم
السلطات في مدينه كيف الشرق اوكرانيا و
تاريخيا كان اقرب لروسيا هناك كثير من
المواطنين يتكلمون باللغه الروسيه واذا
اخذنا تاريخ ايضا اريد ان اذكركم بانه شبه
جزيره القرميه كانت تابع لروسيا وحتى في
اطار الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق اداريا هي
كانت فتره طويله موجوده في داخل روسيا
الفيدراليه وتم نق لكن سؤالي هل الحل
الدبلوماسي ما زال ممكنا صار نعم لحتى
الان الحل الدبلوماسي ما زال ممكن ولكن
الاحداث تتطور بسرعه شديده وهذا ممكن ان
يفشل كل الجهود ال طيب الاحداث تتطور
بسرعه كبيره سيد اندي
هندر مرحله عض اصابع تهديدا تهديدات
عسكريه من روسيا تهديد يعني لغه عسكريه
ايضا داخل اوكرانيا بوضع الجيش في حاله
استنفار دخول النيتو على الخط اليوم ايضا
تهديدات غربيه وسط كل هذه الاجواء هل
برايك ما زال الحل السياسي الدبلوماسي
قائما اعتقد ذلك نعم فلو عدنا الى شهر
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني للسنه الماضيه فان
الاوكرانيين كانوا على وشك التوقيع على
اتفاق مشاركه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي اذ انهم
اختاروا مستقبلهم بناء على القيم الاور
بناء على الكرامه الانسانيه وحريه التعبير
وحكم القانون وفي وقت ما الرئيس
بوتين اقنع اقنع يانكوفيتش الرئيس السابق
يانكوفيتش
بابتعاد عن طريق الشعب والخضوع للنفوذ
الروسي والسؤال هنا في الحقيقه هل ان
الرئيس بوتين يرى مستقبل هو يرى مستقبل
الاتحاد
الجمركي لكن عمل هذا الاتحاد الجمركي
مستحيل دون اوكرانيا وان روسيا تريد ان
تكون قوه عظمى اوروبيه وهذا غير ممكن دون
اوكرانيا وبالتالي لكي تبقى كانان تبقى
قوه كبيره في اوروبا واسيا ولكن ليس دون
اوكرانيا وبالتالي فان اختيار الشعب
الاوكراني كان هو عدم الاستماع لهذا الراي
الروسي وبالتالي ف الان
فانهم ما يقوم به الدور الان هو خلق مشاكل
وليس تحقيق السلام من الجانب الروسي و
وان الغرب قد تدخل مؤخرا وبدا يقدم
تطمينات
لاوكرانيا على انها الدوله تبقى مستقله
كما هي منذ ربع قرن ولا بد من فهم ذلك فهي
دوله مستقله ذات سياده والشعب الذي يعيش
اوكرانيا هم مواطنون اوكرانيون وصحيح
لديهم خلفيات ارقيه مختلفه لكنهم جميعا
اوكرانيون يعيشون بسلام منذ اكثر من نصف
ربع قرن وبالتالي دون اي تدخل عسكري
سيواصل هذا
البلد
لتطور التقدم في المستقبل طيب الينا
سوبونينا يعني في
زخم يعني هذا الاستنفار الغربي الامريكي ل
الى جانب كيف الى جانب اوكرانيا الا تبدو
روسيا وحيده معزوله الا تخشى روسيا العزله
الدبلوماسيه
اولا لا تنسون بانه سكان شبه جزيره قرم هم
توجهوا لروسيا بطلب تقديم المساعده
بانفسهم وروسيا فقط درست هذا الامر وردت
على هذه المطالب فهناك شعوب تشعر بانها
بحاجه لحقوق اكثر نعم ممكن ان تكون هذه
الحقوق محترمه في لماذا اذا لا تطبق هذه
المقاربه على سوريا اذا لماذا لم تذهب الى
نجده الشعب السوري بدل وقوفها الى النظام
السوري رغم انه هذا ليس موضوعنا يعني انت
تتحدثين بمنطق ان روسيا ذهبت الى نجده
الاوكرانيين في شبه جزيره
القرم اولا الازمه في اوكرانيا هي مختلفه
تماما عن الازمه في سوريا ولكن هناك شيء
مشترك وهو انه الخلافات ما بين موسكو و
واشنطن كانت موجوده على سوريا والان اضيفت
اليها الخلافات على اوكرانيا هذا يعني
بانه الثقه ما بين وسطاء الدوليين هي الان
وصلت الى مستوى صفر تقريبا وهذا بالتاكيد
يؤثر سلبيا على ايجاد حلول وسط في مناطق
اخرى في العالم ليس فقط في كلمتين في
كلمتين اندي هندر الحل السياسي ممكن
امل
ذلك ان ذلك ممكن وامل انه سويه مع وزير
الخارجيه ويام هيج الذي هو في كيف
اليوم وايضا بالتوصل الى حل دولي لهذه
الازمه نعم اعتقد ان ذلك ممكن لكن لابد من
سماع اصوات الجميع في الحقيقه انه في
منطقه القرم هناك 100 ال من التاتار وهم
مسلمون ولا يريدون تحت اي ظرف ان يكونوا
تحت حكم بوتين لقد جر اضطهادهم في الماضي
على يد موسكو والحكومه السوفيتيه والالين
و ترحيلهم واضطهادهم في وبالتالي نعم
اعتذر لمقاطعته لان الوقت انتهى شكرا
جزيلا لك اندي هندر مدير المعهد البريطاني
للابحاث الشؤون الاوكرانيه كنت معنا من
لندن واشكر ايضا الينا سوبون مديره قسم
الشؤون الدوليه في جريده ريما الروسيه من
موسكو لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء